[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how things work in night city
stronger survive but that's how things
stand
you're either somebody or you fizzle out
into nothing
then see in a city that lets you get by
without buddies
be very careful my friend we are all so
far from home
which gang's the city's biggest and
baddest according to the ncpd
scavs hold the body count title or
maelstrom depending on the season one
time
a maelstrom ganger killed a young kid
right in front of my eyes
for shits and giggles sucking psychos
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
and can't be i'm gonna introduce you to
our meat grinder
about time we had some fun big belts
you'll never forget
never i hate these pork [ __ ]
she's a gang like any other right i'll
take the valentinos
how'd you meet jackie we started out
together the valentinos
no in the [ __ ] bible book club i
gotta give style points to the
valentinos
they have a punishment for every
occasion
[Music]
quick shout out to everyone in haywood
and santo domingo lately the valentinos
and sixth street have had a bigger bone
to pick
sixth street why'd they want to wipe you
i don't can't [ __ ] stantinos
i've dealt with 6th street before we do
the run they'll transfer the cred
come on let's go before 6th street shows
up
shut up shut up anymore fans of the
house
huh hate those bastards vomit lofty
patriotic [ __ ] all day
time to bring on the future any idea how
many attacks from behind the black wall
we neutralize
if the voodoo boys breach the black wall
we'll all be [ __ ]
voodoo boys urban myth i thought
just netrunners spooking each other no
such gang you know i heard a few things
about you the voodoo boys
best runners in town you do not steal
from the voodoo boys i see you
always for them pacifica is just haiti
2.0 their own island cut off from the
rest of the city
this is our turf our home until last
week the animals crawled in
animals are the craziest [ __ ] gang in
the city
animals aren't the play here are they
they're hired muscles someone else
needed it
i [ __ ] you over you [ __ ] the gang
over somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the corp see how this
works now
my husband's new westbrook very high in
the tiger class
they did what made the best eddies sword
sex and black market
see a lot of tigers they run this place
know what else they do well break the
needs of people who ask
do something shut the questions up the
tigers will kill us
come on baby tiger claws killed one girl
too many
so people took matters into their own
hands
spoke when ballistic girls pimps
outcasts the whole freak show it's how
the mocs got started look at some kind
of gang guru now
us moccasins have each other's back you
look out for one another
you're looking for some company tonight
how'd you hook up with the mox
i thought susie and the gang could
really change something in this city
moxes and nomads don't seem so different
both seem to yammer a lot about
community
solidarity tell me about the badlands
not much going on out here oh contraire
this is an ecosystem nomads raptor shiv
corporations and drifters they form a
complete hole
remove one part the delicate balance
topples
here in the aldocaldos it all stays in
the family
classic dilemma what comes first family
or the outside world
this family will go to hell and back
everyone in this city lives in their own
bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
[Music]
quicksand
you